hey this is preshtal walker reminding
you to mind your decisions
the best number is 73
according to sheldon cooper on the 73rd
episode of the big bang theory
you're probably wondering why
73 is the 21st prime number its mirror
37 is the 12th and its mirror 21 is the
product of multiplying hang onto your
hats 7 and 3.
let's go over these properties in a
little bit more detail
the number 73 is a prime number
it happens to be the 21st prime number
coincidentally 21 is equal to the
product of its digits 7 and 3.
we'll call this the product property of
73.
what's also special is if you reverse
the digits of 73 you get 37 which is
also a prime number it happens to be the
12th prime number and 12 is the mirror
of 21.
we'll call this the mirror property of
73.
this little curiosity inspired a
mathematical paper
in 2015 jesse burns chris spicer and
alyssa turnquist authored the sheldon
conjecture
73 is the only prime number with both
the product and mirror properties
how can we translate these properties
into mathematical language
let's get started with the product
property we'll write p sub n to be the
nth prime
the product property is that n is equal
to the product of the digits in p of n
and we want this to be in base 10.
now let's define the mirror property
we'll define the function reverse of n
to be reversing the digits of n
the mirror property is the following
we want the reverse of p of n to equal p
of reverse of n
so are there any primes besides 73 that
have this property
the answer is no
this year professors carl pomerance and
chris spicer proved the sheldon
conjecture
you can see this in a paper to appear in
the american mathematical monthly
congratulations
they have shown that 73 is the only
sheldon prime that's a prime with both
the product and mirror properties
now how did they prove it
well it's not easy
they used high-powered number theory
involving things like the prime number
theorem the logarithmic integral
function and so on to reduce the search
from all primes to a subset of primes
that are less than 45 digits long
then they went through extensive and
painstaking numerical calculations and
the use mathematica software to figure
out that 73 is the only prime number
that does satisfy these properties it's
an incredible result and it just goes to
show that even a tv show can inspire
mathematical research
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
[Music]
you